(crowd chatter)
- Ahh.
(choking noises)
- Sorry.
Sorry.
I didn't see you there.
("Ranz des Vaches" from "William
Tell Overture" by Rossini)
That didn't last.
- Hey, how's that project coming?
I really need it end of day today.
- I'll give it my full attention.
- You switched off your computer.
What's wrong?
- Nothing.
I'm all right.
- Okay, the end of day buddy.
- Lap it up, fuzz ball.
Yes Crunchy.
I know the transmission's broken.
(dog barks)
- Oh Doritos.
Can I get one?
- These are not the
chips you're looking for.
- No, I love nacho cheese.
They're my favorite.
- These are not the favorite
thing you're looking for.
(loud breathing noises)
- Oh my god.
You're breath.
- Dammit.
- Yes.
Give in to your hate.
Give in to your anger.
- What are you getting
Dad for his birthday?
Do you think it's weird
that he calls me his little princess?
I was thinking of getting
him a Kindle Fire.
I feel like he could
really benefit from that.
What, no.
(disgust noise)
God, Jesus.
Not again.
- There's a lot to explain,
but I think it's best
if you just watch this.
(majestic brass music)
- Why?